hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay got a dragon here
I guess I'll shoot some arrows at it
oh so bro oh no no leave the target
I hit it y'all saw straight slay the
dragon I'm here
where'd you go oh you want to hit behind
the tower cuz you knew you know it's
coming for you right in the wing I hit
it
y'all song where you going where you
going are you gonna are you on I
will I don't know what you guys are
gonna do I can see your tail
I hit it that's totally a hit
ow yeah I seem to be on fire
that's problematic whoops
yeah totally nailed it another bullseye
so pro and everything Oh drop greatest
ever I hit it
yeah I'll hit it again I know balls imma
finish it off with MA
or kiss battle-ax come here yeah
that's right oh yeah oh his skin
oh Wow murder yeah
okay yeah I win y'all saw that
Dovahkiin no no you're fine there is one
Mayfield
in their tongue he is Dovahkiin bragging
more oh hello
that's a lot of stuff looks like you ate
ate a guard there that and at that yeah
that not that no yeah knows that that
fat that oh I've got a mod that reduces
the weight of dragon stuff so it's like
super light
yes
force analytic force where's the magic
shouts there it is okay favorite that
and there we go actually hang on whoops
let's see there we are okay press D to
shout boom
silly I wish the characters had
different voices that was the hairiest
fight I've ever been in yeah whatever
I've been I so many but I'm sure glad
you're with us you better get back to
white one right away
yeah whatever I've got a space core to
see thank you very much hello for this
space cord land in here well
ha ha ha ha hey wait hey where is it
miscellaneous space core hey I know hi
hi where we going where we going
hey lady where we going where we going
I'm not a lady I'm not a lady still
talking to Chelle I thought it was like
ah there's carrot in your inventory will
he say random things as I'm going
through my adventure probably probably
okay now making my way back to Jarl boo
Grif oh yeah can think in the fast
travel Oh No but not the map Oh get
ready oh that's not so bad I thought it
was gonna be like super ultra mega
flashing but that wasn't so bad
alright let's keep a move on
I'm ready for you bring it on of them
we're causing no trouble all we ask
oh okay
we will be back this is not over
you there we're looking for someone in
White Rock uh-huh a woman a foreigner in
the Red Guard Lee not using her true
name okay welcome here in White Rock I
can tell we will be in roar extended
learning Rorick steady that's where the
guy who died like a coward was if that
doesn't interest you
yep we're looking for a fugitive okay
whatever go away I gotta talk to your
booth grief hello hello yes thank you
for not talking to me I'm on a mission
excuse me did I level up I forget
I did not okay I'm good still going get
on my way is niche and I'm tired again
haki dokey
welcome to Dragon's reach here there be
monsters okay
what have we got here shut up
yeah I'm right here what happened at the
watchtower was the dragon dare turns out
I may be something called dragonborn
dragonborn I know nothing you know about
true masters of the way of the voice
uh-huh they live in seclusion growth of
the world the Dragonborn is said to be
uniquely gifted in the voice mm-hmm the
ability to focus your vital essence into
a su3 Charlotte if you really are you
heard you've done it by my writers
Gerald I named you Thane of Whiterun ya
owner that's within my power what about
all the other people that killed the
dragon Lydia and this weapon from my
armory to service your badge of office
I'll also notify my guards of your new
type we are yeah I wouldn't want me to
be among the common rabble did you
return to Whiterun nope yeah oh yeah was
the voice of the cross okay this hasn't
happened in centuries at least not since
Tiber Septim himself was summoned when
he was still Talos about Nora uh-huh
ronger
calm yourself what does any of this Nord
nonsense have to do with our friend here
I'm awesome more awesome than Hugh oh
just let me show you douche Lord
nonsense why you puffed up ignorant
these are sacred traditions uh-huh back
to the founding of the first Empire so
twitchy twitchy twitchy whole twitchy
282 ''tis okay whatever what are these
I'm tired of this conversation let's go
get us some graybeard action whoa oh oh
hello
it's an honor you're not wearing the
armor I remember you in
that's a strange I'd like to look at you
maybe no I can't look at you you're so
beautiful my thing I'm sworn dear sir
follow me the way you seem to be not
clothes properly for combat but this
talk of dragons okay you've gone mad I
say the plains district of Whiterun is
home to up - never mind okay seriously I
don't remember it must be some mod
because I don't remember uh uh I don't
remember
Lydia beings so naked yeah okay
this is it like some armor I can give
her why is she dressed like that last
time I remember playing this she had
armor okay whatever
alright alright come on baby come with
me I did yeah I did I know it's amazing
all right Lydia I think I might need to
get you some armor wait did it even have
an option to leg Livia
take out I don't even know and what do
you want me to carry yes she didn't even
have like her she just has that circle
it on all right let me try to get her
some armor because she's not gonna be
much used to me as a house Carlisle if
she's just a giant pansy in no armor at
all who knows maybe she's like the
biggest badass but it's nighttime and
the shops aren't over I gotta get take a
little nap at the in here hello is that
a euphemism
was that multiple you don't care
sure think it's yours for today thank
you okay you suck boo let me shout my
shout how bad you suck boo
[Laughter]
goal it here we go okay enough of that
that's that just nonsense I can't stand
it you suck Oh No what did i do who my
game ah oh oh oh oh boy I don't know if
this is still recording okay cut okay
we're back I boot him so hard that my
game crashed so anyway he knows how
badly he sucked okay let's see Lydia
come on baby stop forbid diri are in
there mine it's 10:00 p.m. need to sleep
at least ten hours I let's make it
eleven just to be safe so all the shops
are open oh gee MA
Oh flexible ready for battle so serious
shopping bartering is they might say
okay
but yeah oh you just we're standing
there watching me sleep that's not
creepy at all
okay it's a county and white one is
Terrell shut up shame don't care don't
care what security is I'm all this
security of the town needs and who knows
I made it even destroy everyone okay no
chopping wood congratulations let's go
get Lydia some armor I don't claim to be
they take a look alright let's see what
do you have helmet gauntlets shield okay
I'm gonna need her to have a shield
she's gonna have sword and boards so the
shield
I don't want Imperial stuff I want her
to have Horn stuff just like I do
ha but I don't have enough gold dammit
alright she's gonna have to deal with
weight that come from that steel armor
okay she's got I can give her this steel
armor iron gone lets us smithing that's
not bad um alright if I give her the
steel armor that's that's good first
Lydia hello I need to trade you
something you carry all right here take
that what wait what take that there we
go okay now equip that there we go much
more battle sensible me see if there's
other like boots and gloves inside and
that's reason what price hmm blades
helmets pretty much anything to suit
your need anything okay cuffed boots not
bad price there the Imperial gauntlets
but I guess that's okay um yeah that'll
do steel cuffed and then real gone let's
gonna get I don't have enough for that
shit'll doing business with you she has
a weapon Lydia
what do you want me to carry I'll tell
you you just gimme Asst oh good what do
you want me to carry alright here we go
parallel take those and real yeah take
those oh I was wearing the Imperial
balance okay much better now let's go
I'll give two more gear once I get money
which will be after this adventure we're
going on now what are we even doing
totally forgotten
I either way no wait I got time
I forgot crash my timer went forward so
I got that another minute okay I think I
think he thought a thought that we're
going to oh the Greybeards that's right
okay the gray beers and that's where I
need to go um hi Hrothgar I need to go
there okay I guess the closest place to
that is River Wood River would uh let's
go to River wood anyway
yes Argonian whoa look at that beast
look at that monster so tough hmm okay
we're in here um what I need to come in
here for anyway
maybe I could sell some of my potions
that I'm not famed elf thanks again shut
up I don't care about your problems I
don't care I don't care about any of
your problems
hello oh hello hello babies welcome a
bit of this and a bit of that okay yeah
let's sell some potions like all this
probably can go don't need the poisons
just yet I'll get it more into poisons
later
um the resist once again I'll get more
in depth and do it I probably should
have not sold that strength potion
supposed to include notes okay
ingredients now they're worth nothing
okay now maybe I can buy Lydia a she's
fine she's fine
you should come hear me play at the
sleeping giant I will not
shut up vessel Riverwoods agree enjoy my
stop stop talking to me why do you want
to talk to me it's obvious that I do not
want to talk to you okay I need to get
up those mountains somehow I guess I
just hoof it alright whatever
going a little adventure here mm-hmm I
think I think you just go through can't
you can't yeah
maybe you can't hey let me look at the
map okay
others I should I should go to Helgen
all right that's where I should go
Hogan's where the dragon attack was
right I don't know okay anyway that's
actually all the time I got for this
part thank you guys for bearing with me
through the uh-huh little boo session
there but anyway thanks for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye